Would you explain your reservations and concerns with soft tissue radiation, please?
To clarify soft tissue radiation on heart tumors as well.
So by real reservation and concern with soft tissue radiation, quite honestly, my real reservation
is when they do this, you know, blanket or radiation post breast cancer surgery.
I really have a trouble with that. It just, to me, it doesn't make any sense whatsoever.
We're okay. We're going to remove this, this, the, the tumor in the breast, and then we're going
to do, we're going to radiate the whole breast. Come on. You know, if there's
breast cancer cells still there, well, probably there probably is for sure, but you're going to
cause just as many cancer cells damaging the tissue for the radiation. Besides the fact that if there's
metastasis, it's, you know, the, the circulated tumor cells have taken off throughout the body
already, and that's not going to help. But I am not, again, soft tissue radiation against a,
you know, you've got a specific lymph node that you're hitting or a sarcoma or something like that
that you're hitting. Certainly, radiations in the bone can kill or you can get very specific and
targeted on a tuber itself. It's just this blanket radiation that I'm really against.